a truce between presidential candidates
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders is on the
rocks this morning and Hillary Clinton
is stirring up the race by saying nobody
likes Sanders Clinton defeated Sanders
for the 2016 Democratic nomination in a
long and often bitter battle
she tells The Hollywood Reporter that no
one in Congress wants to work with the
Vermont senator the Biden campaign also
called out Sanders for what it calls
dishonest attacks ed O'Keefe is covering
campaign 2020 in Des Moines Iowa Edie
what's behind all this criticism well
Anthony it's because Bernie Sanders is
still very much in the mix here in Iowa
and across the country and if you're
having deja vu all over again we don't
blame you because once again Hillary
Clinton is criticizing Bernie Sanders in
an interview for a new documentary about
her life Hillary Clinton slams Bernie
Sanders saying that through all his
years in Congress he got nothing done
when asked about supporting Sanders if
he won the nomination she said she
wasn't going there yet but Clinton
attempted to walk that back later
tweeting she would do whatever she could
to support the Democratic nominee
back in Washington Sanders tried to
brush-off Clinton's criticism meanwhile
two people actually in the race Sanders
and former Vice President Joe Biden are
once again feuding Sanders had
apologized to the former vice president
after one of his supporters called Biden
corrupt in an op-ed circulated by the
Sanders campaign sorry but that seemed
to end it but just hours later the Biden
campaign released this Bernie's negative
attacks won't change the truth the
Sanders campaign responded leaning into
their attack that when Biden was a
senator he was open to cutting benefits
when I argued that we should freeze
federal spending I spent Social Security
as well other contenders urged their
opponents not to get sucked into fights
the risk I believe we cannot afford to
take is to adopt the same Washington
style mentality of political warfare
that we've come to expect from our
politics
so with the impeachment trial now
finally getting underway Sanders had to
cancel an event that he had scheduled
for here in Iowa tonight Biden and
former South Bend Indiana mayor Pete
Budaj enter campaigning here in the
state today those senators running for
president stuck in their chairs in
Washington are planning to be back here
and in New Hampshire over the weekend
all right ed O'Keefe for said thank you
very much
you